what is a simp
you're asking me yeah okay
a simp is like sort of this term that
it's an internet term your grandmother
probably knows what a simp is right now
simp actually came from the uh the
communities of like i think we want to
say it was only fans really or twitch or
twitter
if you can give a woman a tip on any
form of social media you're you're
that's where the word sim comes from so
simp is the guy who is essentially
spending money or is is has has a a deep
investment in women to the point where
he is self-sacrificing to the point of
to a fault right and in this case
they're spending
the easiest way to understand this is
like if unonly fans for example you've
got guys who are willing to spend small
fortunes and they will creatively come
up with ways to outshine the other guys
that they know are also something for
this woman so that's where you get the
term simp from so you can say it's like
the guy i always thought of it as this
way i thought that the word sim came
from like being sympathetic and that was
the shortening of that and so it was uh
i'm pretty sure that's the evolution of
it i couldn't believe it from simpleton
but uh
yeah but it's a guy who who will do who
will move heaven and earth right he'll
yeah he will uh
he will to the point of self-sacrifice
for
for like zero nothing zero reciprocation
is there any ladies is there any
upside to a guy simping over you yeah
you do because they pay your bills
um do you respect us can you respect us
necessarily say that i
respect them like i would want to be in
like a committed long-term relationship
with them
aka friend zone sugar daddy what is that
there's a difference you're not you're
not allowed to sink on my channel i
block words you can't do anything like
that i don't i don't know what do you
mean what do you do you i block out
things like you're so beautiful let me
buy you this literally on youtube like
so you cannot do anything but compliment
the video or the message or criticize so
i don't like simps i think we have a big
problem with sims really a very
detrimental justin you look like you
want to weigh in on this sympology yeah
go ahead well i think that's costing you
money
you might want to go ahead and take that
money that's the business side of what
we're doing over here you can't buy my
love
i think justin's saying you can't buy
money no no i i don't think they can buy
your love but i do think it's costing
you money and that that's right that's
the well you know i mean the guys are
going to watch the customer if they're
if they're going to super chat you
because you're beautiful and all this
stuff they super chat yeah let them do
it you know that's what i would say
about that but a really good friend of
mine put it really well in one sentence
tristan tate actually says simply
it's the
an equal exchange of value wow that's
all it is it's an inequal exchange of
value it's an unbalanced shame exchange
of value between attention money or
things like that what's the unequal
exchange well it could be done in many
ways
so for example like he and i talked
about it on my show once and he said you
know it's not simply if i if i tell a
girl she's beautiful in her comments on
instagram because me and that girl have
an equal exchange of value i've either
slept with that woman or we have a long
friendship et cetera it's when it's
one-sided yeah so
i'll give you the difference for for
having a friends with benefits you know
[ __ ] buddy versus you know booty call a
booty call is the same thing as a guy
being a friend zone
or um uh the or like a booty call on
this state a booty call think about what
that is right a booty call is a woman
who has sex just have sex with a guy
because it's wreck you know
sport [ __ ] right it's just
recreational sex
and there is no emotional it's it's all
sex with no emotion in it and the
opposite is true of being in the friend
zone it's guys who are like constantly
caught in this friend zone thinking that
they're going to have a chance and if
they just figure out the magic words to
say and if they stick around they're
nice enough and they prove their quality
enough that eventually something sexual
is going to happen eventually they're
gonna have a relationship so for the
woman it is all emotional investment
with no sex
so those two are like they're almost
parallel
but they are an unequal
distribution right but can women do that
can women
i mean i'll ask the women can women
consistently have sex with their [ __ ]
buddy and then have zero emotional
attachment no that's not after no that's
what you're saying
conversation
usually that's three months in yeah
where are we at that's where that
happens how do you handle that
conversation well if you're just trying
to continue
i'll answer that but i want to if it's
okay i'd like to say something what he
just said which is basically
once the man does does that for so long
then he starts to go either that mgtow
or that black pill route and that's when
he ends up in tasha's tasha's comments
calling her names because yeah
yeah so and so that's what happens there
and to answer your question is where are
we at yeah so
that is where i like to go ahead and
just tell them truth
what do you say you know hey i this is
how i look at the world i don't
particularly believe that monogamy works
because what i think happens to the guy
in the relationship that gets fat and
ends up getting left so they get married
right and so there's this masculine and
feminine
dynamic and then slowly as a man like
starts to be with her more and more and
more because he can no longer hunt
and when they say [ __ ] runs the world i
believe that's true i believe everything
in this room and every road and every
bridge and every building we see
some man got out of bed in pursuit of a
woman to go invent build and maintain
everything every night
ever ever and when you take that energy
out of a man i think he dies inside he
slowly starts getting fat and it starts
evening out evening out and now all of a
sudden he can't say [ __ ] to her about
getting fat because he's no better than
her and the polarity's gone that's right
in the beginning i swear it fixes
everything what do you mean like if you
realize that she's not respecting you
and you do the dread thing even if
you're married and you pull back a
little bit and then go to the gym and
make her want to do that that's kind of
how you get that sexual attraction back
because as soon as she doesn't respect
you and she doesn't want to [ __ ] you
you're [ __ ] she'll probably divorce
you oh should she give that five years
she'll probably cheat on you first if
you could see the inside of my face i
showed him the other oh lord i'm like
dude look at this i hand him my phone to
look at my facebook yeah bro what is it
it's just a bunch of i'll show you after
the show
beside it's a bunch of married women
it's a bunch of women with a boyfriend
just saying everything trying to show
you bang them like just like all day
long it's all done they're hitting on
you they're complaining it's all the
above yeah so i i always say complaining
is the first sign that she's trying to
monkey branch if a woman comes to you
and she starts complaining
boyfriend doesn't do this
[Music]